un campo de refugiados en lo que antes
era un parque de atracciones los
habitantes de osmaníe una de las
ciudades del sudeste Turco más afectadas
por el terremoto de lunes por la mañana
se han quedado de la noche a la mañana
sin sus viviendas muchos han huido de la
ciudad otros como meti su familia han
conseguido una tienda en este campo de
refugiados improvisado A las afueras de
osmaniñe y Julio ahí en ese camión se da
comida ropa para bebés allí nos dan agua
té Desde hace dos días todos nosotros
estamos viviendo en estas tiendas Con
mucho frío por las noches y por eso
Hemos conseguido algunas mantas para
nuestra tienda
según las autoridades de emergencia este
campo alberga ahora a 3.000 personas
todas ellas se han quedado sin sus
viviendas Pero ellos son los que han
tenido suerte cientos de vecinos de la
localidad han muerto a causa del
terremoto la necesidad de ayuda ahora es
extrema
veo sobre todo que la gente está muy
asustada y traumatizada y notamos que la
gente tiene que estar muy acompañada En
estos momentos porque las réplicas del
terremoto continúan pero el pueblo Turco
es fuerte
sin embargo y su familia han tenido algo
de suerte ellos a diferencia de muchos
otros tienen algo con lo que cubrirse
por las noches comida caliente que
entrega La media luna roja
tenemos amigos que están teniendo que
dormir al raso mucha gente que no tiene
nada y se quedan con otras familias en
sus furgonetas Sí en sus furgonetas pero
nosotros estamos bien por suerte tenemos
un tipo de techo Pero saben Nunca
tuvimos miedo en el terremoto Cuando
ocurrió el terremoto todos rezamos nos
abrazamos y entonces todo paró y pudimos
salir
con sus ciudades casi destruidas al
completo construir un nuevo futuro es
una tarea imposible para cientos de
miles de turcos y sirios afectados en el
seísmo
como mínimo sin embargo están vivos para
intentarlo